i don't remember the last time i was
this excited because we just got in four
of the brand new macbook pros and guess
what we have four more coming in with
different configurations but today we
are gonna be focusing on the base model
14-inch macbook pro and comparing it to
the eighteen hundred dollar macbook pro
that it directly replaces which actually
has a lot of upgrades compared to the
thirteen hundred dollar model and we're
gonna test everything from the design
the displays the speakers the webcams
benchmarks including real world
performance for photo editing video
editing xcode we're going to test out
the fans and the heat and a lot more my
heart is beating as i open up this 14
inch we've been waiting for this for so
long and we're actually doing something
that we've never done before we're
actually giving away a 14-inch macbook
pro and it is extremely easy to win one
i don't care where you are in the world
i will pay for the shipping any import
fees will take care of that if you're
outside of the us and if you guys want
to win one and not the base model
actually we're gonna give you a specked
up model with upgraded ssds uh and
performance all you have to do is be
subscribed to max tech and comment below
on our launch week video so we are going
to choose after this launch week one of
those videos in one comment and you will
receive one of these machines that are
more powerful than this one man
i've been trying to not not say anything
i'm trying to mention that giveaway this
thing feels incredible um the design
looks great
it doesn't feel that thick or chunky it
has a little bit of weight to it but not
bad but definitely feels different
because it's all flat look at that logo
right there i love that they put it
somewhere because they got rid of it on
the inside there's no rough edges
there's no sharp edges to dig in let's
go ahead and pull out this cable let's
do the boring stuff first this is a nice
cable i guess for the upgraded price
you're getting something nicer of course
we got magsafe that is exciting all
right get up get out of here
all right here we go this is the charger
and by the way if you're ordering from
apple's website make sure you don't buy
this one because this is the 67 watt
charger spend the extra 20 bucks to get
the 96 watt for fast charging but i have
to say this cable is very nice i also
want to mention to you guys that with
these videos coming out with each video
that we're putting out we are adding new
benchmarks new tests so it's gonna stay
very interesting and with that when you
comment below to win one of these let us
know what you guys would like to see in
the upcoming video wait a second how is
this not thicker
look at this on apple's website says
this 14 inch is actually slightly
thinner than the 13 inch but look at
that with him can you see that
difference with the lid it's massive
what the heck all right um
well we have different feet right we
have these pads now
instead of this 13 inch okay let's look
at it this way
all right vadim what do you see now
i gotta i gotta get down over here
because of the way it's shaped the old
one
it looks thinner because it tapers
everywhere but
okay let's look at it this way
yeah it's actually thinner at the
thickest part here but when you look at
this or you just hold it in your hand
it's pretty chunky i gotta be honest
guys the old model did look a lot more
sleek with the concave design but
because they got rid of that that gave
them way more space for one bigger
batteries better fans better speakers
and all of that stuff that we are gonna
test now another thing i just noticed
looking into these vents on the 13-inch
macbook pros they only have exhaust
vents on one side and then the other but
the new 14-inch has vents all the way
through for great exhaust and then as
far as these intake ports they are
slightly shorter but a lot deeper and
wider for more easy airflow getting
sucked in you know what guys i have to
do this i have to take off the covers on
these to see the insides this is
something that i have not seen anybody
post so let's grab our ifixit kit and
see what lies inside of here this video
is not sponsored by ifixit by the way
but it is by our merch and we actually
have new m1 pro and m1 max shirts the
maxtec m1 pro shirt so you guys can
check that out in the description if you
guys want to support us
and
this thing is done if you guys know
about these macs these are such a pain
to open up i'm interested the 14 inch is
a lot easier
all right there goes the 13-inch model
as you guys could see we have dual fans
for this 1800 one uh for the 1300 one
that the m1 replaced you only had a
single fan i'm excited to see if this
can be a lot easier to open and see
those fans that supposedly have up to 50
percent more airflow let's get this
thing opened up here by the way guys we
actually have another exciting
announcement this is a crazy week we are
launching short form content so if you
want to see little clips like this one
right now before they go up on a video
you guys can see it early by subscribing
to the max tech shorts channel or tick
tock or instagram if you guys want to
see those videos we'll have links down
in the description below all right guys
the moment of truth
let's pull up all right we got some
clips there that's so much easier that
was you guys didn't see how long it took
me to get this off all right my heart's
beating let's take a look all right look
at that wow so we have
multiple battery packs look how thick
those bad boys are they're thicker than
here we have one two three four five we
got these subwoofers and looking at the
fans
they look interesting because we have um
the smaller fan the fans themselves look
smaller these modules the little airflow
areas look larger
and we have airflow here but what comes
out there with through those extra
exhaust ports um we have as far as the
heatsinks we have one large one and then
we have the m1 pro chip right there look
how big that heatsink is that is
covering it's super long i don't know
what's here on the side uh here it's
definitely a lot smaller let's see if we
can peek under this sticker here guys
this is very scary hopefully we don't
damage this thing before we get it open
why it's almost empty
what the heck is that i thought it was
gonna be maybe like ssd or ram
no we have an apple chip a tiny apple
chip
some other i don't know transistors then
that's it all right now we have to open
up the other side i gotta see what's in
there too interesting this has something
else we have no apple logos here i see a
renaissance chip i wonder what that is
looks like it's a 16-bit buffer that's
26 dollars and 45 cents it's a non-stock
item takes 20 weeks to order one if you
guys know what that is let me know but
other than that what we're seeing are
larger speaker drivers these subs right
here if you remember previously did we
didn't have six speaker systems for this
one so i'm excited to test that out we
also have larger enclosures here we have
what looks like to be the ssd right here
at the top so definitely i mean the
whole thing has changed around here look
at this if we stack these side to side
the logic board is actually longer which
leaves less room for the batteries even
though the battery capacity is 20
larger and i don't know about you guys
but we expected logic boards to be
smaller with these new apple silicon
chips now not only that look on this
side with this fan how much wider it's
literally twice as wide the exhaust from
this fan itself and then here it's
actually probably about the same maybe a
little bit more outlet so we have more
heat possibly coming out of here
and a lot better exhaust system and i
thought apple would maybe skimp on it
but no and after looking at this i'm
excited to see if we have a completely
different cooling system for the m1 max
model and what those fans and heatsinks
are set up to be but for now let's go
ahead and shut this down and let's get
into the comparison getting back to the
fronts look how much larger the apple
logo is we didn't get a glowing one but
it is much bigger and you guys can see
how much larger the footprint is on the
14 compared to the 13. let me go ahead
and stack these up evenly so you guys
can see it's probably about a half inch
wider and then on the front maybe about
a half inch or somewhere around there um
deeper as well on the left hand side we
now have magsafe so let's test that out
that's a satisfying click right there
and i love the little led now along with
that we have two thunderbolts four port
slash usb4 and a headphone jack now it's
moved from the left side which i love
because i'm sitting there with the mouse
and i have my headphone cable right
there in the way that is no longer going
to happen and then looking at the
opposite side we have an hdmi port it's
not the fastest one but it's there and
it's convenient to have along with
another thunderbolt port and an sd card
reader instead of having two thunderbolt
ports on the right side of the older
macbook all right i gotta check out an
sd card let's pop it in
look at that vadim yeah it's not it's
not going in anymore looks like apple
did not want to waste any space on the
inside
looks like uh if you want to buy an
older flush mount sd for older macbooks
it will not work because this thing
barely goes in there alright the moment
of truth let's open these bad boys up
there we have it i like that sound turns
on automatically what's interesting is
this little cutout isn't as deep as it
was before apple even saved space there
to get more internals in look at this
guys the screen does not angle as much
as the old one that is very odd and look
at that notch staring me right in the
face
yeah that thing is definitely noticeable
there's no way you are going to miss it
but with that look at the bezel
difference right here it looks like the
side bezel is less than half as thick as
a 13 inch and then on top it's probably
like a third of the thickness so even
though we have that notch this
definitely looks much nicer and look at
the keyboard look at that massive escape
key and how we have that double anodized
black finish below that's an extra step
of anodizing the apple has to do which
they didn't have to but it looks great
and then of course we do not have that
touch bar anymore we have these large
function keys as far as the feel
it basically feels the same i can't tell
any difference the track pads are
identical no difference there and then
the touch id button is now uh larger
with the rest and it's circular just
like the new imax compared to our square
one from before and now that we're all
set up i want to test out the new
speakers and the webcam but first look
at that menu bar up there it is so much
larger than on the 13 inch even though
the screen is bigger it's actually
slightly taller than the notch so that
it doesn't you know look weird but the
weird thing is i actually went into
these settings and what i found is that
when you go and you switch out the
scaling for more space like i always do
the menu bar doesn't change it stays
huge everything else just gets smaller
on it so that is interesting whereas
before it would always scale to your
settings and of course when you go full
screen it completely disappears so there
are no distractions and now
let's get into the speaker comparison we
have the new six speaker system here
let's see how much better it sounds
[Music]
[Music]
all right guys wow did you guys hear
that
man i was blown away there's a couple
things i wasn't actually expecting first
off i thought that the 14 inch is gonna
be a lot louder than the 13 inch but
it's not in fact i actually thought that
the 13 inch was louder and that's
because there's so much high frequency
sound in this machine and this one the
highs are actually a little bit more
balanced but then when i used my apple
watch i thought that the old macbook pro
peaked at 79 decibels compared to 80
with the new one and throughout that
song it is actually slightly louder on
the 14 inch so it is louder but what
really gets you is the base the new six
speaker system with those dedicated
woofers wow it's like if you have a
cheap car steering your car and then you
upgrade it and you add a dedicated
12-inch sub
that's the difference we're hitting all
those bass notes and it sounds so deep
so rich really really nice on the
14-inch we're here with the 13-inch even
though this has an upgraded speaker
system compared to the 1300 m1 mac
it just it does not compare and all your
base is coming from the mids man now i
do wish the highs were a little bit
brighter on this because i do like those
bright highs but overall it is just a
game changer and now let's compare the
webcams i have both opened up right here
and i'm gonna switch between them as far
as the video and the audio so you guys
can compare which one looks better and
which one sounds better of course the
old macbook pros have a 720p webcam with
pretty good mics the new 14-inch has a
1080p webcam with upgraded studio
microphones and it has an f 2.0 aperture
so it should be better in low light so
right now vadim shut off the lights and
now that our studio lights are off here
is how the 13 inch macbook pro looks and
we get some shifting once i move around
if you guys can notice
the exposure changing and then here is
the 14 inch with that larger sensor the
1080p with a better lens you guys let me
know does it look much better than the
13 inch model comment down below and now
let's compare the lcd display to the
brand new mini led pro motion display
right off the bat we have a higher
resolution we have almost 6 million
pixels compared to about 4 million
pixels so about 45 more pixels and of
course we have the 120 hertz refresh
rate compared to 60 you can lower if you
want everything seems much more smooth
you can also go down to match your
content save battery life here's some
slow motion clips of just that pro
motion smoothness but what i'm most
excited about testing is the hdr with a
thousand it brightness up to 1600 nits
so let's go ahead and open up an hdr
movie right away i could tell a
difference in contrast the lcd display
even though apple's lcds are great it
looks great compared to pure black on
the new 14 inch and then those
highlights on those cherries
man all right same thing here we have
our displays kicked up all the way um
and then that allows the hdr to go into
full effect and as far as reflectivity
i don't know if the coatings are
different i know if you guys see me in
that top camera uh but this one does
look a little bit shinier but maybe it's
just the fact that the blacks are so
dark look at that guys you see the gray
there the black there let's go and shut
off the light so we get rid of any
reflections wow look at that guys
looking at this end game hdr trailer
massive difference in blacks with the
lights off and then those highlights are
really popping on the 14 inch xdr
display this isn't even dolby vision
this is just from youtube overall the
colors look very similar but we have
better contrast with the new display and
the highlights do pop more look at that
difference right there look how much
brighter that highlight is and then how
much better the contrast is compared to
the lcd display now what about blooming
well if we go to a pure black screen
with the highest brightest
highlights for our menu bars you can
definitely see it just like on the ipad
you have this glow around the white
spots but of course on the lcd display
of the 13 inch you have that blooming
pretty much everywhere because it's a
single backlit not different zones but
as soon as the lights are on all that
blooming goes away i might see a tiny
hint uh but pretty much at this distance
you can't see it and i've watched a lot
of movies on the ipad with this new
display
and you really don't notice it even in
dark situations in real world use so the
screen upgrade is definitely a massive
one now the videos i played here they're
from youtube for some reason my apple tv
app it will not let me play anything
with dolby vision and that's what's
actually going to give you those 1 600
nits of peak because on youtube these
videos are about 700 or so so it
definitely will get even better maybe
we'll be able to look at that in a
future video and now let's finally get
into performance we have a lot of
exciting tests that we are going to
cover but i want to start out with ssd
because apple after i think five or six
years now changed it to the latest and
greatest so let's start this out and bam
right off the bat we have 2200 compared
to 4144
and as far as the read speed that is
actually pretty low i got 1800 oh there
you go there you go it fixed it i guess
it's like speeding up we have 1800
compared to
4770. i ran this a few more times so we
can get the best results with each and
it looks like as far as the right we
have over twice as fast with the new
14-inch and the reed it's two and a half
times faster now of course this is not
hitting that 7.4 gigabytes a second that
they mentioned this is the base 512 ssd
same thing over here we got 512 so later
when we compare the 14-inch bend model
to the unbind with a one terabyte we'll
see if we get faster ssd speeds with
that model now let's get into geekbench
five we're gonna see the performance of
these new cpus both have 16 gigs of ram
it's interesting to see that now we
actually see the gigahertz 3.22 slightly
higher than the m1 for this m1 pro but
let's go ahead and run our cpu benchmark
and i do want to say that this 1800
13-inch macbook pro did have a newer 10
gen processor with g7 graphics 2
gigahertz compared to the cheaper
version which had an older processor all
right guys we have our results and look
at this our single core went up by 47
that's a significant difference in
day-to-day simple tasks but the
multi-core from 4400 to 984
that is almost 2.25
times faster that is a massive
difference of course we're gonna see
what that means in the real world and
now let's test out the graphics for a
variety of compute tests i know there
are benchmarks out there for the higher
end shifts but this is the base bend
model so i'm excited to see how well it
does compared to the g7 the best intel
integrated graphics that had a good
upgrade from the previous one all right
guys if you guys thought the previous
result was a big upgrade wait till you
guys see this we have 10 157 which is
almost double compared to the previous
generation that had intel to
35
428
that's what like three and a half times
faster and this score right here i
believe a demon might write was this
better than the 16-inch with dedicated
graphics yeah man it's actually better
than the base 16-inch so before if you
would have bought that 5300 m just
because you want better graphics this
thing has it now this is a 14 core now
even though we have these huge
differences with geekbench they already
mentioned that the scores are lower than
they should be because the this machine
is just doing those tasks so quick it's
not ramping up the frequency high enough
so let's go ahead and close this down
and open up gfx bench i'm going to run
the aztec runes off-screen 1440p test
because that one will not matter
depending on the resolution to get a
true result let's go ahead and see what
this thing could do for gaming when it's
optimized for metal all right guys we
have our score oh my goodness video look
at this
26.7 right for metal gaming 26 fps
points out it's a tough test right
147.258
26 147 so that really shows the unified
architecture when you have something
that's optimized uh when the gpu is
accessing that memory and the cpu it's
quick right there this is the bin chip
this this yeah you're right this is the
bin chip
that's over five times five and a half
times
faster performance for metal optimized
gaming now will those games ever come
vadim does seem to think so i hope he's
right there are some optimized games but
geez louise that is a huge difference
from three and a half overall compute to
five and a half now all right guys it's
time to bust out the thermal camera
let's see what happens in terms of heat
i've seen a bench open but before
we start this and see how hot do these
machines get how loud do the fans get
what performance we get i want to show
something to you guys i didn't want to
mention it before but at this point i
have to plug in the intel mac because we
are at 15 battery power once we're doing
install the install setting it up
shooting the previous part before we got
into even the really heavy stuff you
guys see right there and our 14-inch
macbook pro okay it's 49 it was just at
50 just dropped down to 49 compared to
15. now we didn't want to make this a
battery life test because they weren't
both fully charged we're going to do
that for the next video we'll start them
at 100 but they started actually very
close i believe this one was at what 88
or 89 percent the other one is at 86 or
87 percent they are very close but you
guys see the difference right here even
with the display that's brighter uh
running hdr and larger alright so now
that we also have a interesting little
reveal here that cinebench is giving us
it's saying that for multi-core it's
running at three gigahertz estimate not
3.2 like the m1 ran for multi-core or
for single core but we will see what the
truth is now first i'm going to take out
my thermal camera and let's see the
temperatures it looks like we're getting
35 degrees celsius at the hottest part
36 right there for the intel model
and our m1 right there 32 and a much
smaller
hot spot now as we go on when we're
running through this benchmark
we will see what happens in terms of uh
fans and heath and all of that stuff so
let's go ahead and start our throttling
test bam we are started i'm gonna go
ahead and open up intel power gadget
here right away you guys see we ran at
32 41 watts 39 watts 40 right there so
it looks like the intel cpu is sucking
up 40 watts of power at least until it's
gonna have to slow down a bit and we are
running at about 3.3
gigahertz now over here we don't have
that same readout but i did open up
terminal here and right there cpu power
21.2 watts so almost half the power at
the start and it looks like it is
running at 3.228
gigahertz so for now we're getting full
performance and bam you guys hear the
fans right there so we have the fans
about a minute and a half in those
kicked up
they are running at right there almost
maximum which is pretty high 6
6864 rpm and 6 300 rpm on the other side
so fans are maxed out and we're running
at 26 watts on the 14 inch m1 the fans
are running at 2400 right over to check
it out they're not even
20 i don't even think they're 25 maybe
20 or so
they are running nice and cool now
unfortunately we don't have full
breakdowns of temperatures yet here
we're at 86 degrees now cooled down a
little bit it was a hundred if you guys
look at it right over here um here the
high temperature i see is 52 degrees i
don't know exactly what that's for but
it might be the cpu who knows alright
guys so it's been five minutes all the
temps have settled in wattage is solid
in look we got 41 or 42 degrees celsius
for the hot part of the intel macbook
pro and the the new one wow 42 degrees
as well
at the hottest spot now that spot is a
lot smaller on it compared to the intel
model
but in terms of fans
these things have barely sped up right
now they're probably about 25
speed
still 55 56 degrees celsius compared to
settling in at 85 degrees
and then a clock speed of 3.0 so we are
thermal throttle here all right guys
this is very interesting look at this
we're at 41 degrees celsius sometimes
drops to 42.
look at the heat on the actual macbook
screen and then look at the m1
43 44 degrees celsius on the hot spot
look at those warm marks on the display
now that is because
the vents are way more open on this
14-inch right up here when you open the
lid all the vents have access here on
the 13-inch older design it's blocked
and it tries to put it out the back
there so this has a lot more airflow
which is probably why
i can't even hear the fans what i'm
hearing is the fans on this one they
have to work way harder whereas here now
we're what maybe like a third of the fan
speed
and it's running way cooler alright guys
we are finished not only did the 14-inch
run way quieter pretty much silent
and it also ran cooler at least the cpus
itself this whole area got quite hot
though the performance difference is
substantial what we have on the 13-inch
4
348 points it did thermal throttle down
to like 2.8 by the end of it compared to
9472 points for the m1 pro the binned
version as 6 performance cores that is
2.17 times more powerful over double the
performance and that is a pretty good
upgrade compared to the previous version
that this one replaces so now we know
all the temps we know hey fans and all
of that
let's close this down and get into real
world performance the first thing i'm
going to do is compile an xcode project
now our friend maxim ermenko that
created this project for us he made us
an easy way to test this to make sure we
get consistent results we have this
terminal window open that's going to
start the project the compile bam it is
already running on it and compiling our
cpus are maxed out at both look at that
97 98 degrees celsius on the intel model
the fans are kicking up look at the m1
pro the fans are still completely shut
off cp's is hitting 100 47 degrees
celsius is the hottest point we have on
the laptop all right the m1 pro finished
before the fans even spun up let's go
ahead and wait for this one the fans are
full speed now on here we'll give it a
little bit longer and pam there we go
the intel is finally ready it can cool
down now
what do you guys think how long do you
think it took what's the difference you
guys could comment below
our m1
took well let's start out with this one
this one took 309
seconds to compile that project compared
to
111 seconds that is almost three times
faster for compiling which is
interesting because with the other tests
that we did the difference wasn't that
big so for a project like this we have
xcode it is optimized we have the
unified memory you guys can see the
performance difference right there and
right there not including the other
stuff just upgrading from eighteen
hundred bucks up to two grand for this
new model little more but look at the
performance and this is the binned
version and now for all of you photo
editors out there let's see how this
does i'm going to start out in lightroom
classic doing an hdr merge test which
always takes a while let's go ahead and
import both of these
bam pretty quick on both let's create an
hdr file from these nine 42 megapixel
images from the a7 r4
right away the m1 is going pretty quick
here we have the menu bar it's pretty
much sitting let's just sit and wait
here bam that merge right there
let's select it so it creates the final
file this thing is just sitting here bam
the m1 pro is done that's a tough test
that took two minutes and 15 seconds for
the whole process all right and bam
right there the intel mac is done and
look at that the difference isn't as big
as i expected two minutes 15 on the m1
pro and three minutes and one second on
the intel mac so not far behind and now
let's take that file and let's enhance
it with adobe super resolution we have
uh the estimate time is going to show up
here and then we'll actually enhance it
oh look at that badeeb two minutes to
enhance at least the estimate compared
to ten
seconds okay so let's see how long it
actually takes i'm gonna hit enhance
start my timer so we went from nine
images into one look at the hdr looks
fantastic and now let's go from 42
megapixels to what i think it's double
or quadruple but let's see how long this
takes it's taken a little longer than it
expected but and done right there i
guess i was a little over optimistic for
the m1 pro saying 10 seconds because it
actually took
47.98 let's call it 48 seconds now we
have a huge file and the intel that
thing is still going at 100 degrees
celsius and bam we are done with the
intel one that one was more accurate for
the estimate two minutes and pretty much
two minutes 15 seconds compared to 48
seconds now i wonder if the hdr made it
tougher because we have done this with
the m1 at about 10 seconds but this is a
crazy file this entered into 166
megapixel image that's hdr and it did it
almost three times faster and now let's
export these 50 raw edited 42 megapixel
files our classic test and see how fast
the m1 pro is all right wow
that was fast for the 14-inch macbook
pro
is that even faster video do you
remember what my mac pro got the 12 core
196 gigs of ram for this test all right
so i guess it's not faster than that
that is still really fast but it is
faster than every other system that we
tested that's a max system for a base 14
inch all right guys well we have the
results for both we have a minute and 44
seconds for the 14 inch and three
minutes and 53 seconds for the intel so
that is over twice as fast about 2.25
times faster for this export very very
good improvements and keep in mind both
have the same amount of ram as well so
very good there let's go ahead and close
this and now let's get into video
editing i'm starting out with the
standard project that most people work
with and even the older intel macbook
still handled it really well because of
the upgraded graphics that it got
and how well final cut is optimized but
let's go ahead and see what happens when
we export this five minute project that
has two luts and film grain appliances
and bam we are exporting we're gonna
start the timer this is hevc i've been
recommending to export that for a bit
now because of the quality then one pros
at 30 compared to 12 on the intel and
what's interesting is that neither of
these machines are actually maxed out we
have 30 cpu 68 gpu compared to 16 cpu
and 59 gpu on that one pro so the
encoders are actually the limitation
here and we are using that t2 chip
that's built into the intel 13-inch
macbook pro and bam we are done right
there and i have to mention that the m1
pro is still on the original battery
we're at 14 now whereas this thing we
plugged it in we unplugged and plugged
it back in just because the battery is
draining so quick here we're at 42 so we
got a while to wait all right the intel
is finished
wow okay so that took six minutes and 19
seconds and if this was h.264 project it
would be like over 10 minutes but with
c2 encoders and the most powerful
13-inch intel microphone that you could
ever buy we got six minutes and 19
seconds compared to two minutes and 35
seconds for the 14 inch base pro so that
is what vadim almost three times faster
or so right around there now i have to
tell you guys that this project is
actually limited to the encoders
encoders for the m1 for final cut are
limiting it but final cut is not as
optimized as davinci resolve now if you
don't believe it or not because this
project would finish in about a minute
and 30 with davinci resolve which is
crazy but we are going to be doing a lot
more video editing tests a lot tougher
ones in our upcoming videos so make sure
you guys are subscribed but right now
what i have to do is
get rid of that limitation of the
encoders we'll do something a little bit
more tough with prores this is prores 4k
raw files here
we are playing both of them and they're
both playing back pretty smooth i'm
seeing some stuttering in the timeline
here so maybe it's not perfectly smooth
might be dropping some frames uh but the
cpu wow 72 compared to only 20 on this
one yep there is some stuttering here
even though this is very well optimized
so we are going to take this five minute
project as just simple color corrections
not a bunch of luts and we are going to
export it to prores four to two let's
see how they do oh my goodness oh
do you guys see that right there 28 30
31 33 35 skipping percentage points 38 4
40
41 i can't even speak right now 45
compared to five fifty percent compared
to five percent
fifty five percent okay our mac is
starting to die do we need to plug this
thing in or should we wait i don't know
if it's going to limit it at all
but it is flying okay let's let it get
finished bam it is done a minute and
seven seconds for a five minute project
pro res raw
4k and here we're only at 13 seconds
okay well this is where the power is
really shown when we're not limited by
those h265 encoders
that is wow that's a crazy difference
all right guys i can't wait any longer
we just hit 50 here it took five minutes
to hit 50 percent
uh and it's being pretty linear so i
will say basically this is going to take
10 minutes for this 5 minute project
which is still not bad
but the m1
pro 14 inch base model binned version
took a minute and seven seconds that is
pretty much ten times faster
when you're dealing with these prores
raw files and you know what guys believe
it or not my fifteen 000
mac pro
with the 2 000 afterburner card included
in there took a minute and 47 seconds
12 course 196 gigs of ram after burner
card for 2 grand a minute and 47 seconds
this base model banned macbook just did
it in a minute and seven that is
absolute insanity i don't know what the
other ones are going to do because
they're just so much faster we will see
soon how fast those are what my mac pro
if it's 13 grand instead of 15 you don't
get that afterburner card takes two
minutes and 45 seconds compared to a
minute and seven that means this thing
is more than twice as fast if you don't
buy the afterburner craziness alright
guys well there we go we're just gonna
cancel this export we're gonna save this
intel macbook pro
there you guys go
that was basically a slaughter fest not
only did we have way more performance
sometimes twice the performance
sometimes three times or five times or
even 10 times but the battery life this
thing is basically twice as good
even though this is the 14 inch model
which doesn't have as good battery life
as a 16 inch so tomorrow we will
actually do 100
unplug and then see real world battery
life give you guys the full results uh
but if you still have an intel macbook
pro it is worth upgrading better battery
life way better performance better
display speakers you guys saw the
webcams and fan noise is almost
non-existent while you're getting that
performance so yes it's 200 more for the
2021 compared to the 2020 intel model
but it is well worth it and this might
be one of the biggest upgrades ever you
guys let me know your thoughts down in
the comment section below remember you
need a comment and be subscribed if you
guys want a chance to win not this crazy
fast model an even faster one with
double the storage so if you want that
just make sure you guys check that out
hit that subscribe button and then with
that if you guys want to see short
videos from us we now have a youtube
shorts channel page tick tock instagram
those are all linked down in the
description below go ahead and check us
out there for lots of quick short
content and we will see you guys in the
next video
[Music]